l'importance, on va voir la
photo de ce trou noir, de
cette...
découverte, de cet assemblage?
incroyable et puis là, on plonge
encore dans la Voie lactée.
Et moi, je peux voJ'adore mon mr
ça. C'est pour pouvoir faire
ces sauts temporels, ce voyage,
ce tourisme de l'espace à la
différen
qu'on effectue parce qu'on peut
aller n'importe où avec ces
images-là; c'est .
Cette image-là, elle est
notre trou noir de la Voie
lactée, il est très petit,
beaucoup plus petit que celui9
qui était dans une galaxie
pourtant très lointain, mais qui
était vraiment très massif, ete
masse que celui qu'on a
actuellement. Il faut se rendre
compte que ce que l'on voit là,
c'est vraiment une image du trou
noir, le trou noir est au ceit e
très très vite autour de c
noir, qui émet de la lumière
parce qu'elle tourne très vite..
L'anneau que l'on .
- Oui?
- ... il fait à pl'orbite de lae
qui tourne autour
Donc on parle environ d'un
diamètr
kilomètres.
- Waouh!
- Et la matière sautour, très t.
- Qu'est-ce qu'il ya a àya a àyà
l'intérieur? Est-ce que c'est
une mass
des questions naïves,
enfantin
- Non, non, non...
- Qu'est
Ce n'est pas un trou. La masse,
llement compacte que
ça... ça gravité, ça absorbe
tout?
déformation de l'espace-temps.
le terme technique d'un
trou noir, puis c'est une
déformation à l'infini. C'edirei
rentre n'arrive pas à s'en
échapper et cette matière est
transformée en énergie; c'est
une grosse boule de masse. À ce
niveau-là...
- Donc il n'y a pas de masse?
- Oui, il y a une masse, mais
la masse, c'est aussi de
l'énergie. C'est ça toute
la beauté de la relativité
générale et d'Einstein, de
E = mc2 qu'on a pris comme
es bancs des bancs des bancs de.
Il prend toute sa valeur ici
parce qu'on est vraiment à
conversion entre la masse ete. a
devant les yeux, c'est une
illustration parfaite deelativié
générale et de ce que Einstein .
- Je vous repose la question :
Ça nous donne qifiquement?
- Ça vérifie scientifiquementlaé
générale, ça, c'est sûr.
Pourquoi? Parce quir cette
image, on a dû faire des
comprendre comment se
mment
évoluerait un trou noir, forme
il aurait et les différentes
formes qrent trèrent trèrent trà
l'image image qu'on a obtenue.
C'est une confirmation nette et
précise de la théorie de la
relativi
Ça va nous amener plus loin, ça
va nous amener à  comprendre
savoir, on a encore beaucoup de
mystère : Pourquoi on a un trou
noir central au centre de not
là? Comment il est apparu? Est-
ce qu'il est apparu en même
moment de sa formation? Ou est-
ce que ce sont des phénomè
cataclysmiques qui sont à sonuna
formation de la galaxie? Et
surtout à? On sait qu'il va
rester un bon bout de temps,
beaucoup plus que l'âge de
évoluer? On va pouvoir le suivre
campagnes d'observations dans
les prochaines années, en 20
et en 2024. Comment va évoluer
ce trou noir, quelle va être sa
beaucoup de choses qui vont
sorti de ça.umière
de la Terre. Comment on a faitpa
fai? N'est-ce pas une photo...
Comment
- On utilise une technique qui
s'appelle l'interférométrie. Ce
que l'on fait, c'est qu'on fait
télescopes et ils sont
éparpillés partoutue de notre
planète et on fait croire
simplement à la lumière qui
arrive sur la planète Terre
qu'on a ètre de la terre. Ce qui
fait que ses performances,
sa résolution est la meilleuable
de voir des fins détails mêmesn.
La solution qu'on obtient... En
fait, on serait caalle
de tennis ou un beigne sur lasua
résolution est précise ou encore
une pièrait
l'observer depuis Montréal.
- On ne dormira pas personne de
la nuit. Ça éveille de l'anxiété
de parle
de tennis ou un beigne sur la
surface t la
résolution est précise ou encore
une pièce de 25 sous situé à
l'observer depuis Montréal.
s personne de
la nuit. Ça éveille de l'anxiété
de parler de l'immensément
on ne voit toujours pas... vous
allez me dire : ma
instruments, il y a un nouveau
télescope qui est parti, on ne
Voie lactée, je répète qu'
On ne voit toujours pas sur dess
2 milliards de soleils dans
notre galaxie, je ne parle pas
dans les autres, de vie?ement,
notamment avec le groupe
institut de recherche de
s
traces de vie dans les autres
planètes que vont
télescopes comme le télescope
spatial. L'objectif est d'aller
c'est extrêmement complexe parce
rouver ça,rouver ça,rouver ça,rl
faut analyser les atmosphères, s
facile à dire, mais il suffit
d'attendre un exo planète passe
devant sr la
lumière avant et après qu'il
différence. La lumière en
on regardait toute partie de
lumière, c'est très faible comme
signal,
spécialistes capables d'analyser
tout ça. Le télescer dans cettea
et les futurs grands télescope
qu'on est en train
sur la planète Terre, des
aider à analyser un peu plus.
rouver des
signes de vie sur les autres exo
planète. Peut-être qu'on n'a
plus de chance de m'en trouver
de persévérance sur
mars...
- Dans notre système solaire çan
se dit q
elles sont la, n'est-ce pas?
- Elles sont là,
évident... sur 200 milliards
d'étoiles on peut avoir deux ou
décomptevident que quelque part
il y a de la vie, il faut juste
la trouvde
foin. C'est ça qui estdifficile.
- Monsieur Hernández, il y a
davantage de soleils dans letéee
sable sur la terre, qui avaient
dit ça?
- Carl Sagan, il a tout à fait
sont très grandes de découvrir
- on voulait souligner cet
exploit scientifique qui a é
aujourd'hui, merci beaucoup.